a lot of people ask me about
khabib and that fight
i want it to happen khabib wanted to
happen but ufc did not want to happen
between you and khabib yes and we tried
to make it like about three
three years ago when i when i retired
two you know three no it was after
two years ago and it didn't never came
to fruition
the ufc were clear they said they would
they have other plan for khabib
and it's makes sense to for the business
standpoint because they want to keep the
ball rolling
now can be retired and like everybody
else after just justin gaitrey
i was doing the comment theater in
french for the ufc and i
had butterfly i thought he was going to
call me out
if there's one guy that i would have
said yes it would be him because for a
fighter the most
exciting thing things to do it's often
the scariest
one and khabib was you know where is the
scariest matchup
yes but it was worth the risk
because nobody have ever been able to
solve them
how would you solve the khabib
nurmagomedov puzzle
well khabib is very good against the
fans
i would have to establish a game plan
and everything but i think
uh what i would needed to do is take the
center of the octagon right away
use a lot of fake and fate keep the
fight
all the way all the way out or all the
way in and when i sell the win is when
you close the gap use my proactive and
reactive takedown and my
perhaps my superhero explosive to put
him down
i like to use those proactive and cr and
reactive technology because for me i
feel it's more economical
khabib is a much better chain wrestler
than me
chinese stories when he got the guys to
the fans it's pure wrestling
what makes my take down very efficient
it's my karate it's not my wrestling
it's i'm a i'm very good at timing my
opponent
and getting in with with my explosivity
so if you watch my takedown it does not
demand
often it does not demand a lot of work
when i use the i call it proactive
takedown
when um he's coming to punch me and i
react so
i mean proactive is when when i i'm
faking it so
i i i i instigate the tech ground by a
fake
then i take take him down and reactive
is when he's
i'm baiting him to throw something and
then he then have a counter
yeah yes but all my take down in the
center of the octagon
yes my takedowns are more in the center
of the octagon like for example another
guy that does it well is gleeson tebow
that did it well
in his best days you know khabib has
more
a style of chain wrestling i would say
like kamaru uzman or sort of speak
kind of kind of guy it's a different
style you cannot compare both town
and that's the kind of takedown i'm good
and i would if i would have fight kevin
that's one of the strategies i would
have adapt i would not have been afraid
because everybody that i thought i was
able to put them down
and and and i have the pedigree to prove
it in my
fight resume so you would have perhaps
see him on his back and i would have
perhaps be on my back as well so it
would have been a very interesting fight
and
how hard do you think he is to take down
i mean a lot of people speak about his
wrestling being just
it has nothing to do with it like that
the wrestling because let's do the
correct
if i get that timing and i got my both
hand around around his knees
he's going down everybody goes down yeah
yes yes this goes down and
and and i had a lot of uh that's what i
would have done i would not have been
afraid of his wrestling
uh i would have beat the instigator i
would have
forced the fight forward and that's what
that's how i would have
approached that fight which i believe
most of his opponent
were afraid of his wrestling because
they didn't have the tools that i have
to put him down
i would not have forced the wrestling i
would have in in the clinch i would have
tried to disengage i have many ways to
disengage the clinch
i would have wanted to force the fight
in in that in a
in a fighting distance you know like in
in a shoot box distance not in
a wrestling distance is it possible
this fight still happens i
your young look great in the suit
well there's a lot of problems now
and the thing is now i made peace with
it
i no longer don't wanna fight and i
don't it's not gonna happen ufc
was not interested and i'm bound by
contract with the ufc
and by exclusivity there there's some
people says to me oh how about if
russians are a crazy a a
wealthy russian guy come with the money
yeah
i said i'm gonna be uh in court with ufc
and and also i'm older now and when i go
home man i'm like
i don't want to do this you know like
and we're always like this
i don't want to do this but like for
example i was training with freddie
roach a few days ago and i'm hitting
pads you know
and freddy's looking at me and he's like
hey you have the hitch back i'm like
yeah
if dana white would walk in the room in
the in the gym
at that precise moment with a with a ufc
contract
i would sign it sign it in the blink of
an eye
but when then after i go home i'm like
hell no
oh no my belly is full my my you know
i'm healthy i'm wealthy
why would i want to fight for i made
peace with it
but the minute i go back in the gym
because i still get it inside me when i
train with the young guys
i still get it and a lot of guys thinks
hey
tell me the truth you're preparing a
comeback cause i still get it you know
i'm a little bit
older but i i get more knowledge i can
compensate
i i i become a different animal because
you know it changed you but then after
you go home and you
you're like man no way i'm doing this
yeah it's very hard to explain you need
to be acquired
to understand that it's very very hard
to explain
well from your perspective i think
khabib
is one of the rare one of the few
fascinating scientific puzzles yet to be
solved
so from that aspect as a martial artist
it's just a fascinating journey to try
to solve that puzzle
there is a thing too like say oh who's
the best fighter people
legs they don't like i underst i i
realized that
later in my life and i'm sure a lot of
young guys will say oh i said if there's
not
don't speak for me but i'm telling you
right now what i'm about to say you will
realize it later
when i was young i think you can
proclaim yourself the
more the badass men on the planet you
know like nobody can beat you at
it's an illusion man that's the sad
thing about for example dc
uh daniel cormier does probably one of
the greatest
if not the greatest of all time you said
miyotis but like
it's almost because of that little
matchup with jon jones
it's it's difficult for people to
conceive of him as the greatest of all
time
it's all about matchup it's all about
timing and
also you make a fight you make both guys
fight 10 times
the result might be different like
like every time you know i mean maybe
he's gonna win
eight out of ten but that knight is
gonna he's gonna lose
why because we don't know that the
universe made it like that you know
maybe he got sick maybe he had the
emotional issues he didn't sleep well
and he makes him
lose focus and he got caught you don't
we don't know
but it's it's that's the thing with
people ask me would you have done it
with khabib
what would happen i don't know maybe out
of 10 time i don't know maybe
as a fighter i hope i would have win
more than him
he thinks the opposite is only one way
to find out but
that night if there's a fight the ghetto
gonna win doesn't mean he's the best
fighter that's mean
the the is the one that fought the best
the night of the fight same thing in
basketball or aki
the team that wins the game it's not
necessarily the best team
is the team that play the best the
the night of the game and fighting is no
different so being the
baddest man on the planet it's an
illusion
i mean that's the tragic thing about it
is uh on any one night
anything can happen and then that tells
a story for all of human history
is it's uh it's sad
it's sad to think about but that's what
makes it beautiful that
there's so much at stake like entire
lives
all the dreams you've had growing up all
the hard work all of it is decided in a
single night
even though that means nothing in terms
of who's actually better
it's uh i mean that's the beauty that's
why people love the olympics especially
because it happens so rarely
and dreams are broken or
like triumph is achieved by the unlikely
hero
all like right there i mean that's
that's why we love it right that's why
that's why i love it if we would know
always the result before it would be
boring that's why we do it you know
you